welcome to this video playing new
Mariano's number regions from Spain yeah
okay I really don't know what the petrov
very well so yeah this is this line is
kind of a reversed reversed berlin the
other way I don't know it probably not
so important okay let's try to get some
normal development going here you for
saying so d3 the C intending Knight a5
maybe is okay I want to also plan to
prevent Bishop to g4
yeah black is certainly quite solid here
maybe maybe I should have thought about
this slightly longer because know upon
structure really looks ugly okay but I
got some some piece of Dimity
the real question is how to continue now
he can take and play into his success
one possibility what am i doing now next
yeah just castles or is there some more
more interesting idea getting the Knight
to f5 or something okay come on this is
rather rather risky maybe or dubious no
but let's let's try for something
interesting intending Knight h4 to f5
how do I take now not sure really
both captures made some sense
yeah a form a form before him
it is rather weakening on the Lites
class yeah but still I can play Bishop C
183 C for patch that okay Matt is
somewhat weakening
yeah Knight to f4 quite quite a weakness
on f4 yeah it was clear that the G form
was somewhat somewhat risky but no wait
after g5 where's he going
I have 96 Xena but at first I can
dislodge the snide 96 the IACP
overlooked ed but mellitus of course a
strong piece at some anyway anyway it's
a it's an exchange probably I should
should take this temple
no NIDA for my king is still is still
very shake him
no naughty for didn't want to we can
dead as well never taken place see for
himself which actually is quite a good
idea I wait I can I can do that this is
this is good
Queen d6 quickly trying to 26 is got
Queen a5 okay Kappa g5 for a moment it
can play 96 f4 LF I have it all covered
objectively speaking it should be
excellent for white I think but in in a
practical game it's not so easy
each was actually mistaken I needed to
play Quincy form may be okay but if he
plays c4 which was what I what I feared
I actually am have this Bishop III idea
yep that it's not great for my bone
structure but still the Queen's office I
played this very quickly
yeah maybe have attested this really is
good really is good
possible wait am I getting should see
five you can actually play 96 proxy for
b6 very very annoying
oh yeah 94 check
check
I'm not so sure about that actually
aren't you tying all your stuff together
no somehow yeah this should be a draw
really
check
time warning
check
yeah position is of course dead now but
can can try on time as usual
you know he doesn't try on time this is
real
yeah complicated stuff yeah it was clear
that he's got lots of compensation with
with this this says crime on d4 Derek h3
is strong rock edge 3 yeah yeah this is
indeed strong covering from the side and
if he takes now Queen b5 their queen d5
yeah this is quite strong
a white half could control and he's got
but I've got we should a3 also that's a
possibility of Bishop III yeah this is
looks like good control in the game this
is this is really dangerous
yeah I thought I thought this but he can
just play here because this is losing
this Bishop fortunately
yeah he certainly had a good position
probably winning
check-check
all right computer gives this is pretty
George yeah after this it's it's it's
okay I think four four four white would
be fine was also possible at this should
be should be a draw really yeah thanks
for watching